all right
see you
and it's a great
segue from
Collective behavior in Surprise
minimizing agents two Collective
behavior in Surprise minimizing agents I
guess welcome Connor
hey so I just turned on my audio so I
just heard the last thing you said yeah
okay
yes thanks
um
we're looking forward to your
presentation multi-agents active
inference and multi-skill Alignment
current developments and challenges so
feel free to share your screen or
proceed however you prefer
great thanks and before I start can I
just um because I've had issues with my
my voice like saturating like my
microphone saturating how's my audio is
it clipping at all or does this sound
okay this this is good and I'm watching
it
okay perfect thank you
um I will share my screen
I'm going to share this one and then the
one thing I'll note oh yes okay it's
just JF symbolic implementation does not
use statistical distributions it uses
the
um symbolic and The Logical inference
and now we're going to move back into
the distributional space and it'll be
awesome to see similarities and
differences so thank you Connor to you
for the presentation
and thank you um Daniel for the
introduction and for inviting me as well
as big thank you to the other organizers
of the third applied active defense
Symposium
um yeah I'm really happy to be here to
pick presents so my name is Connor Hines
I'm a PhD student at the max Park
Institute of animal behavior and I'm
also a researcher at the versus AI
research lab rmd Lab
um so I'm gonna do something a little
bit I guess unconventional for
people in my position like I'm a junior
researcher coming to the end of my PhD
so usually when I give a talk I would
present on my own research
um like what I've been up to for the
last 10 years working on but instead of
that I'm actually gonna talk about
giving the motivation of the Symposium
I'm going to talk about something that's
more of an overview or perspective on
the current state of the field in
multi-scale active inference or
multi-agent active inference
and what in my opinion we need to do to
move forward as a field I think that's
very um resonant with the kind of
motivations and the title indeed of this
Symposium so I'm going to give a general
analysis of what multi-scale activations
is why it's important I'm going to
provide a brief analysis of its formal
basis as it currently stands and then
what we need to develop in this kind of
sub-discipline of active inference
multi-scale active inference to really
make it rigorous and really to actually
reap the benefits of what it promises
um so generally active inference has
been used a lot to design agents that
can solve problems plan and just
generally emulate behavior that we deem
intelligent which includes things like
Risk sensory decision making intrinsic
motivations to resolve uncertainty and
finally from a more scientific
standpoint the ability to furnace a
process theory about how biological
brains actually might work
um but in a lot of the theoretical work
on active inference from the last 10
years is or 10 plus years really there's
also alongside all the kind of practical
building adaptive agents there's a claim
that active inference is inherently or
intrinsically multi-scale from the very
get-go it is a multi-scale framework
it's not just about building single
agents
um so it's really whenever we write down
a single active inference agent what
we're implicitly implying is also a
nested hierarchy of active inference
agents both below and above so
colloquially you'll often see this in
papers as the idea that there's Markov
blankets all the way down markup blanket
is a statistical structure that's very
kind of
um intrinsic the definition of Agents as
they are defined in under active
inference so I'm not going to get into
defining that I'm kind of assuming that
there's a more disciplinary audience
there but I'm sure other touch feelings
Symposium can provide better Clarity so
yeah Markov blankets active in things
all the way down all the way up
and at any given scale crochet the free
energy minimizing Dynamics or the active
inference Dynamics are kind of claimed
to be aligned with or parallel to the
free energy minimizing gradients at the
level below and above so what what the
claim is that as agents are doing their
thing and doing active Infamous at one
level it both entails and is constrained
by active inference processes of the
macro agent that they're participating
in so I'm a cell that's part of a tissue
as well as the microagents that comprise
them I am a free energy minimizing
cellular agent comprised of organelles
that are also minimizing free energy
so this this kind of constrained neat um
nested gradient descent on free energy
is part of the story of multi-scale
active inference and it also crucially
assumes that these Dynamics are aligned
correlated Cooperative across these
different scales so I should mention
that there is a formal argument made
more recently I would say in the last
five years about how this is possible
and it relies on an apparatus from
statistical physics called the
renormalization group this basically
allows you to analytically identify
shared symmetries energy and
conservation laws at different scales in
a given system that's comprised of
subsystems and subsystems so on at
infernium so there's a formal argument
specific we made in the a free energy
principle for a particular physics
monograph from 2019 that applies the
renormalization group apparatus to
multivariates stochastic differential
equations that are kind of the
equivalent of a regions so you can apply
that that framework to certain sorts of
coupled stochastic differential
equations that exhibit Markov blanketed
Swatch coupling structure and you can
kind of prove analytically that there
are going to be domestic systems of
Markov blankets and that they're all in
some sense to minimizing three energies
at their Urban scales so I'll get more
into that argument later but I just want
to mention that as I Define multi-scale
active inference that
um that there is a formality that that's
related to it
so this slide I just put together to
demonstrate the idea of nested free
energy minimizing processes visually so
at a given scale we can think of an
agent as occupying some point in its
free energy landscape indicated by this
Red Orb which represents say its
configuration its beliefs and its
actions and it performs active inference
and in doing so minimizes its free
energy so it changes the position of
that ball on that landscape and that is
all we mean when we say active inference
that that corresponds to the agent doing
inferencing doing action and kind of
getting to the fixed point of its local
free energy landscape
the multi-agent case is simply when we
add more of these processes so there's
other agents usually assumed to be
similar agents and the word similarity
let's put the asterisks on that and
they're all sitting at different points
in their own free energy Landscapes
they're all the the position of their
local Red Ball is maybe in a different
place
so the claim of multi-scale active
influence is that as we link these
multiple active inference agents
together so they can actually exchange
information like observations and
actions with each other what we
automatically get is some kind of super
agent that is also minimizing variation
of free energy and is in some sense an
emergent or supervenient active
inference agent and I say the word we
automatically get a super Engine with an
asterisk because there may be some
conditions on that mapping from local to
Global that have to be elucidated
um so we'll come back to that in a bit
but in short I think the the definition
of multi-scale active entrance is very
eloquently put in this paper by
um Raphael uh Kaufman pranav Gupta and
Jacob Taylor I think Rafael Kaufman is
actually going to be on the panel later
um and this line from their paper is a
really nice uh I think just summary of
what it is
so I'll just redo that right the upshot
is that in theory any active inference
agent at one spatio temporal scale could
be simultaneously composed of nested
active infant agents at the scale below
and constituent of a larger active
infantation at the scale above it in
effect active inference allows you to
pick a composite system or agent a that
you want to understand and it will be
generally true that both that that agent
a is an approximate Global minimizer of
free energy at the scale at which that
agent reliably persists and that agent a
is composed of subsystems a sub I that
are approximate local minimizers with
free energy so that is the claim as I'm
going to like continue continue
evaluating it in this talk and I think
it's just a great reference point to
make
so okay that that that's what
multi-scale active inference is why is
it important why do we actually care
about that that sounds philosophically
nice and beautiful visually but why is
that important so there's a ton of
actually really important implications
of this both for the engineering and the
Natural Sciences
um first of all the namesake of the
Symposium I assume inspired by this
recent paper by Carl ferson at all about
enacting ecosystems of
you know parenthetically shared
intelligence so this is the third
applied active inference of opposium so
to to really make this resonate with the
applied aspect let's make this very
concrete if we can figure out this
multi-scale endeavor then we can
actually engineer distributed systems of
multi-aging intelligence where local
agents and doing their own little local
active inference processes are also
cooperatively instantiating a global
agent that's also performing active
interest this has huge computational
potential of course compared to kind of
the state of VR predominant methods for
artificial intelligence which are deep
learning which really is about
propagating Global Information through
an entire computation graph so although
you could argue back propagation is
local in some sense it's really not
local in the way that multi-scale active
influence promises to be local so if we
can figure out how to actually engineer
multi-scale academic difference it will
have really tremendous implications for
the study of artificial intelligence
just from that pure engineering
standpoint
it'll be cheaper in one where it'll be
computationally energetically Memory
wise cheaper a lot cheaper secondly
from a kind of more Natural Sciences
motivation which is kind of where I'm
coming from I get a p I'm doing a PhD in
biology so I'm interesting questions
about actual real systems in nature just
the idea of being able to get super
specific and rigorous about phrases like
emergence intelligence emerging
computation collective intelligence
super organism that's often thrown
around we're talking about social
insects right these are terms that you
hear thrown around in many different
scientific disciplines that deal with
multi-agent systems um Network systems
but none of these terms to my knowledge
have really rigorous or precise
conditions multi-scale active inference
is a kind of framework that's in the
position to provide those rigorous
definitions and conditions so from a
scientific standpoint it could really
lend a lot of potential and usefulness
for other scientific disciplines and
finally another pragmatic motivation
there's loads of fields that are
obsessed with designing and Engineering
Systems where local selfish individual
Behavior can lead
when networks appropriately to some
desired Collective outcome and these
disciplines you really want to figure
out how to engineer that properly so
this goes from the design of financial
markets and trading systems all the way
down to how do you design a multiplayer
video game
so that that's kind of just motivating
why is multi-scale active influencing
and interesting
so then the question of course becomes
is the multi-scale active infancy claim
actually true are all multi-agent active
inference systems comprised of and
themselves comprise nested hierarchy of
free energy minimizing agents
a glance at a smattering of other
scientific disciplines that specifically
deal with multiple agents multiple
interests Collective phenomena like
coordination group Behavior collective
intelligence
I'll go answer all those disciplines
would naively suggest that their answer
is no so there's things like frustration
in thermodynamic systems Game Theory the
very existence of zero-sum games and
Nash equilibria bandwagon effects when
we're talking about social networks and
and um opinion Dynamics
um sacrifices for the common good which
we see in different contexts in biology
like in the context of kin selection but
also in the context of arguably cell
cell death in a tissue
um these are all basically plenty of
systems where local constraints and
Global constraints or desires or free
energy gradients whatever you want to
call them coming to direct conflict so
the obvious example that I I listed at
the top of these on bullets is the idea
of geometrics frustration that we see in
ising systems with very low temperature
so these izing models basically describe
lattices of ferromagnets that are happy
when they're pointing in the same
direction as their neighboring Fair
amendments and they can be in an up or a
down state so basically the magnet can
be pointing up or pointing down and
these Global Systems are defined by a
global energy function and the whole
system is in some sense trying to
minimize that Global energy function but
sometimes you'll find cases in these
Collective systems where this little
spangle in the middle cannot be happy
because they're getting conflicting
information from two neighbors I want to
be pointing up in blue like the agent on
the left but I also want to be pointing
down like the Asia on the right so this
is a system that's collectively finding
some fixed point of its Global free
energy but it's actually leading to a
local conflict where this agent is not
at a point where it can do anything to
make itself happy or minimizes free
energy further so just from even the
basic glance at uh ferromagnetic
lattices we already see instances where
local and Global gradients or local and
Global Optima are not aligned in the
right way
so given all this the burden of proof
for multi-scale active infants is still
on up so we need to show that Collective
active income systems generically do
align again across scales and maybe if
we can put an X across the word
generically and it's not some automatic
condition if they don't then at least we
have to establish exactly the conditions
in which they do
so anecdotally we do actually have some
conditions
there's some seem to be some kind of
basic ingredients to get Collective
Collective active inference to work so
one is that we basically need agents to
exchange actions and Sensations across
some kind of Markov blanket this is not
really a condition this is almost more
part of what it means to be an agent so
having more confidently gets separation
between agents is just another way of
saying we have multiple agents in our
system rather than a single agent if
you're violating a Markov blanket
property so internal states of One agent
are not allowed to see the internal
States or external states of another
agent then you're kind of cheating
because you're kind of saying it's
actually One agent and what you're doing
is information sharing within the brain
of a single region the second condition
which is something that's often
hallucinated more anecdotally and not
really formally is this idea that agents
need to have some kind of shared
narrative or shared hidden States or
censor space in their generative model
so I've worked a lot on Collective
active inference systems just simulating
agents and trying to get them to do
interesting things together and my
intuitions and experience do agree with
this basic fact if the agents don't have
any similarity in what they're
representing or trying to achieve then
it's kind of like trying to fit a square
peg into a circular hole so this is
really nicely elucidated in the one of
the earliest cases in this paper a duet
for one by first in the first in 2015
where they show that for two agents to
really align they kind of have to have a
shared generative model and then you can
get kind of this nice synchronized
Behavior
again though these things like what does
similarity mean what does a shared
narrative actually made formally
mathematically those things have not
been initiated yet so right now a lot of
the building of these Collective systems
is based on our intuitions and kind of
engineering things in using some vague
guidelines like oh they should have a
shared sensor space but there's no
mathematical conditions or guarantees
about what degree of similarity is
needed between two agents models to get
the intended Dynamics
and finally we have to have at least
some agreement between the generative
model of each agent and the generative
process which is really the behavior of
the other agents generating their data
so this is kind of related to the the
previous point about average share
generative models but just to be very
specific
the physics of the space that transfers
your actions to my observations that
physics can't be dramatically crazily
different than how our generative models
represent those physics so if we took
two fish with the same generative model
of each other and they normally would
school together in a fish tank but we
throw them in a volcano or shoot them
out into outer space they won't school
together because then the generative
process is so dramatically deviating
from the way they're representing that
physics the way they're generating model
is constructed so these are again just
ingredients kind of guidelines or
anecdotes but there's nothing really
rigorous Behind These conditions they're
more like a list of best practices
so now let's get on to actual rigorous
stuff so the first real rigorous attempt
to show that multi-scale active
inference generally works is in one
section of this free energy principle
for a particular physics monograph from
2019 so it leverages this apparatus I
mentioned earlier the renormalization
group operator to basically show how one
can successively course screen
multi-variate stochastic differential
equations that admit sparse coupling
between their state variables so the
main result in my mind that connects
these remobilization group results to
multi-scale acts of inference is the
fact that the lagrangian of the system
at one scale can be expressed as a
function of the lagrangian at other
scales and that applies in a scale
invariant fashion that is the main like
uh kind of output or the main benefit of
using a renormalization group apparatus
so you can kind of think of LaGrange
like the generative model it's a it's a
physics Trend but it's related to the
generative model of the agents that
comprise the system and therefore also
their free energy so in terms of active
inference it means that this reasoning
of the renormalization group can be used
to smoothly move between the models of
individual agents at one scale and the
model of a collective or larger agent at
a different scale or a smaller scale for
that matter and the nice thing about it
is general for all kinds of Dynamics and
thus generic models it doesn't depend
heavily on the form of the stochastic
differential equations that form your
system
um the issues with it is that there's
not a Global Link to basic mechanics and
active inference it's still all done in
the traditional physics formalism so we
don't actually have an explicit link to
local inference and Global inference
although if you know the connection
between the lagrangian and the
generative model and the free energy
then you can make that connection but
it's not actually made explicitly for us
in this part of the monograph it also
requires the assumption that the
generative model and the generative
process are identical at the local level
that's where we need to have lagrangian
is defined that's also a restrictive
assumption that's probably not realistic
in my opinion and then finally there's
something about uh kind of spatio
temporal segregation of scales so we
need to make assumptions about how fast
random fluctuations are at one scale
relative to another scale in order to
justify kind of core screening or
forgetting about certain States As you
move between scales and that's also
something that you could argue current
Research into Collective Dynamics
challenges that that assumption about
how how fast noise is that one scale go
up to the to the next
so now I'm going to discuss quickly
another small contingent of active
inference research that is attempted to
address this mapping between local and
Global Insurance processes so what I
want to kind of just generally say with
this presentation and to our community
is that the kind of approach taken in
these two papers first of all active
entrance model of collective
intelligence and speaker glass systems
there's Collective active influence this
is one of the types of research I think
we really need to move active inference
multi-scale active inference forward so
I'm not trying to be too biased because
I am the first author on the second of
those papers but I'll also be the first
one to point out the limitation but
benefits wise I think these approaches
are really important because they
formally relate a local generative model
at one scale to a global generative
model at a different scale so really Tai
how do the parameters in one model
relate to a course grade model and these
are really good um steps in the
direction of a formal theory of
collective intelligence that goes from
local intelligences to Global
intelligence
however there's still issues with these
one of them is that they only deal with
the issue with infants at the global
level not active inference so these both
these papers concerned with a bunch of
local active inference agents that
cooperate to form a global inference
agent like a passive-basing agent rather
than an active inflation and it's also
unclear whether the system studying
these papers are actually very generic
like the results are generic to studying
collective intelligence in general or
their nice formal arguments but they're
only applicable to these specific
systems so we still don't have something
that's even more kind of zoomed out and
Abstract than these which tend to be a
little bit case specific and finally the
actual
um scale Transcendence that we're doing
in these papers is still relegated to
really one step we're not doing the full
multi-scale infinite scale regression
that's something like renewalization
group promises
so that's kind of the current overview
of what I think are the most promising
directions when multi-scale active
infants and I'm aware on time sorry five
minutes so I'm going to quickly try to
go through what I think are really
promising directions to push in terms of
multi-scale active infants and kind of
intuition products that I think will
help us
study these systems in a way that's
different and also actually better
informed by other research disciplines
so the the general idea that I'd like to
put forward is that misaligned gradients
can actually be a good thing so it's
actually sometimes good when local free
energy gradients are misaligned with
global grains so sometimes the global
system will actually do better if the
local systems are performing worse so
this is something you could call
multi-scale conflict with a free energy
minimizing process at one scale are
actually doing bad quote unquote but
it's because they're being driven by
some higher scale process that is doing
well so rather than trying to always
avoid constructing processes like this I
think this kind of frustration to use
the analogy from statistical physics can
actually be an inspiration for what we
should investigate further because it
actually might be key to facilitating
optimality at different scales
um the reason I put this forward is
because there's loads of research just
Recent research in the last several
years that are suggesting that actually
making local agents more frustrated or
more unhappy might coincidentally or not
coincidentally lead to better Collective
or Global outcomes so this is expressing
various forms in various bodies of work
but one of the biggest patterns I've
noticed is the study of collective
Behavioral Systems over the last several
decades is the idea that local noise and
local dysregulation can often facilitate
Global coherence or the global
coordination and where multi-scale
active inference has something to say in
my opinion is in framing this benefit of
local frustration in terms of a
misalignment of free energy gradients so
maybe that actually temporary
misaligning local free energy energy
gradients from Global ones may
facilitate the dissent to fixed points
in the global free energy landscape that
satisfy everyone at all scales so I'm
basically expressing an idea that's been
known in various communities like
stochastic optimization and stochastic
resonance theory for decades but I think
we as active influence practitioners
have a newer and potentially useful
perspective to shed on that using the
language of that given for inside free
energy and minimization and Bayesian
inference in general so instead of
thinking of accelerating optimization by
just adding noise to the system we can
think of exactly how to design local
generative models such that there's an
optimal misalignment of local and Global
gradients or locally Global generative
models in a way that facilitates
everyone in the long run actually
facilitating or minimizing your free
energy
um so yeah that's just kind of like a
something I'm putting out there I'm
investigating it now in my own work but
I have no real results on that but I
just want to put that out there in this
venue because I think it maybe will
inspire other people to think in a
similar way
so just to conclude now multi-scale
active inference I would say is still
largely based in theoretical or
philosophical descriptions and
illustrative simulations but we're still
lacking a formal Theory
um there's some theory in terms of the
renormalization group arguments of the
monograph but they're still in my
opinion a bit underdeveloped a little
under demonstrated and rely on some
restrictive restrictive assumptions like
the fast and slow fluctuations the
identity between generative model
generic process
there's a few more recent papers those
two by um Kaufman at all and then by
myself on spin glass systems that have
attempted particular proofs of
multi-scale Bayesian infant systems in
particular situations but their
generality is still not known and not
proven so we why I'm kind of trying to
conclude with is by saying we need to
incorporate findings from other
disciplines related to the role of noise
conflict and frustration in facilitating
not subverting collective intelligence
or Collective coordination and I think
we can really benefit by looking at
these other disciplines to help us build
a really powerful formal theater
multi-scale active inference and finally
I think we need to set the goal post for
what counts as a formal proof of
multi-scale active inference and once we
get there the ones we say okay this
causes proof this is satisfying how
could we use that to actually
um do the the hardest part in my opinion
which is engineering actual multi-scale
active inference systems that are
intelligent and minimizing free energy
have multiple skills
um yeah so with that I'm going to
conclude it looks like I'm just on time
so yeah thank you again for the
invitation to present and I'd like to
thank a bunch of people who are listed
here and Beyond who have influenced my
thinking in kind of my opinions
um yeah if there's time and happens I
take any questions of course
awesome great
talk I'll just give a few seconds if
anybody wants to type in a question also
it's really cool like aswin in the
previous session was highlighting pi mdp
and just the way in which
we enact the collective intelligence
different people seeing a paper where an
analytical formalization is introduced
and then there's still so much work to
get it to the package and then so much
more work to take it to the Last Mile
and I think your presentation really
checked a lot of those boxes
um I'll just read a question and then um
that will just be an appetizer for our
continued discussion so Marco Lynn asked
do you expect the inferentially
connected Dynamics to exhibit Behavior
akin to theories of multi-body systems
and to what extent can we transfer
insights from that multi-body of work
and then second question just
for our thinking and learning from Marco
have you explored integrating work with
uh integrating work on self-organized
criticality with multi-scale active
inference or other Frameworks who can
provide more flexible Frameworks or
assumptions for a generic notion of
multi-scale Dynamics great questions
I hope that we can continue
um have you back anytime or just
continue to collaborate in the ecosystem
so thank you for the Epic talk Connor
and good luck finishing your PhD
thanks a lot Daniel yeah I'll talk to
you soon
talk to you soon